a cool priest yeah no I'm a big reader  with no friends are you a cool person oh  I'm pretty normal person a normal person  that makes you a normal person well I  don't believe in God  I love it when he does that I've never  thought structure first I've always  thought material first jokes first  character first let me just put them all  on the wall and then honestly just the  game of what if you put this next to  this and usually the more unusual that  pairing is with those scenes or those  scenes you put in an episode The more  interesting it it comes with something  something happens when you put two  things it should be together and then  you start pulling a story out of that as  long as you're enjoying writing those  scenes then then once you've got enough  then start playing with